oui mais je le faire avec les québécois
mais que s'est il passé pour que toutes
les firmes de sondage au québec se
trompe de 10 points dans leurs résultats
on avait tout en main pour avoir une
bonne prédiction pour le moment on en a
pas d'explication les sondages c'est la
spécialité de claire durand son verdict
est sans appel
ils se sont trompés gravement elle
estime que c'est un problème
d'échantillonnage
habituellement les 55 ans et plus votre
un peu toujours de la même manière d'une
élection à l'eau mais si cette fois ci
il y en a la moitié qui décide d'aller à
la cac
j'aimais 55 ans et plus mais j'ai
peut-être pas les 55 ans et plus qui ont
décidé d'aller à la cac
dans mon échantillon car ils nous
promettent des choses qui peuvent pas
faire si les gens nous disent n'importe
quoi que vous voulez qu'on fasse pour
alain giguère les gens ne manquent pas
mais ne disent pas nécessairement la
vérité aux sondeurs
le fond du problème c'est que des gens
qui nous disent pas vraiment pour qu'ils
votent ils ont une attitude quand il
répond d'un sondage
et quand il sera mort dans l'urne là ils
ont une autre ce que comment voulez vous
qu'on prévoit çà de là où on s'est
trompé semble-t-il c'est dans la
sous-estimation majeur de la cac et de
la surestimation majeur aussi du parti
libéral
les libéraux se sont retrouvés en
premier un casting les philippe fournier
de québec 125 compile tous les sondages
pour faire des prédictions
son explication est la suivante je
voudrais aussi que plusieurs électeurs
libéraux sont carrément à rester à la
maison en 2014 libéraux ont obtenu 1,7
million de votes
ils ont été réduits à un million de
votes donc ça fait sept cent mille
électeurs libéraux qui sont restés chez
eux ou qui ont décidé de choisir notre
parti c'est énorme
il retient au moins une leçon de ce
cafouillage de ne jamais oublier que les
sondages malgré qu'ils soient
scientifiques
c'est une mesure incertaines nous
mesurons l'humeur des gens alors
pourquoi ne pas simplement ne plus les
utiliser
on ne peut pas les éliminer parce qu'on
est en démocratie
les seuls endroits où il n'ya pas de
sondages c'est dans les dictatures
même s'ils sont un parfait les sondages
font partie maintenant de notre réalité
ici catherine kovacs radio canada
montréal